Yeah,
I haven't made any public comment on it
and I'm not going to start on this show.
Everybody has a timeline of the time
that you have to come to vote,
but I think that it's likely to be
decided before then and,
uh,
I,
I probably will decide along with most
others.
I think Howard Dean was suggested at the
end of June,
if I'm not mistaken.
Uh,
I'm from Maine.
I represented main in the Senate,
but I'm now a resident of New York.
Primarily I,
when I left the Senate,
I remarried.
I had young children.
My children go to school here.
So you sort of,
that's what you end up,
uh,
as a voting taxpaying citizen.
Uh,
uh,
when Obama won the main caucus,
I got a bunch of letters and calls from
people because they.
And I thought I'd be a,
again,
a superdelegate for me and I've been a
sub delegate from Maine since I left the
Senate.
And,
uh,
they said,
well,
Obama won in Maine,
so you should vote for Obama.
Then a Clinton won in New York.
Uh,
uh,
and I got a few calls from Clinton,
people saying,
well,
you live in New York,
you ought to vote for Clinton because
she wanted New York.
And then the Democratic National
Committee announced,
yes,
in fact,
I would be a adult soup delegate from
New York.
So then I started getting calls from my
Obama friends making a completely
different argument.
And both sides argument have shifted
over time.
Uh,
if you say a d,
should you,
should I vote in accordance with the
majority in the state?
That's New York.
Then I would vote for Clinton.
Should I vote for the majority in my
congressional district?
Should I vote for who wins the popular
vote nationwide?
Should that popular vote include or
exclude Florida,
which is likely to be a determining
factor?
Who Wins?
I mean,
each of these has an argument in and of
itself,
but I guess my feeling is I feel much
like I did in the Senate when I had to
advise a consent on presidential
nominations.
The constitution doesn't define what you
do.
So I think I should use my best judgment
taking into account and give,
given great weight to the way others
have voted.
And there are,
as I just mentioned,
numerous iterations of that you can look
at one of several factors,
including the number of delegates they
have,
one through the elective process,
but in the end,
making a judgment which my conscience
and judgment tells me is the person who
will best serve the nation.
And as a Democrat who will be most
likely to be elected.
Uh,
if I did,
I wouldn't tell you because that would
of course that defeat the purpose of any
mediation.
Uh,
uh,
and I don't.
So I'm not giving any secrets from you.
Uh,
and I don't think it's likely to happen.
I,
I think it's all going to work out
before then.
I know you're not a reporter in the
strictest sense,
but you know,
the press has an interest in
controversy,
keeping it going and devising scenarios
that suggest a conflict right down to
the last minute of the last hour of the
last roll call at the convention and
maybe beyond.
But I think reality is to the contrary,
I think it is likely to be resolved to
not too long after the last primary or
caucus.
That's not very far away.
We've waited this long.
We can wait another week.